let us turn to the left's repulsive
response to Monday shooting at the
Covenant School in Nashville Tennessee
because this was a Christian School
targeted by a transgender killer
thoughtful heartfelt remarks from
Democrats in the media mob they have
been few and they have been far between
some are actually mocking the victims
take a look at your screen now the now
former press secretary from for Arizona
governor Katie Hobbs posted that tweet
after the shooting with the caption
Quote us when we see transphobes okay
she has now since resigned in disgrace
but has offered no apology now sadly the
vitriol didn't stop there one awful
Progressive talk show host quote joking
about the victims not praying enough
that's supposed to be funny I thought
attacking one's personal religious
beliefs was not allowed in the leftist
woke world we live in now meanwhile a
transactive activist from Harvard a law
implying that the victims got what was
coming to them because of Tennessee's
laws against so-called gender affirming
care and and drag shows NBC news they
touted the true victims for Monday night
shooting quote Tennessee's trans
Community who are now fearing for their
lives amid a focus on the Nashville
Shooters gender identity now predictably
other Democrats they're using this as a
political opportunity to ban guns blame
Republicans very predictable far left
teachers union president Randy
Weingarten calling on the federal
government to confiscate guns like
Australia New Zealand uh maybe Randy if
you're watching maybe why don't you
focus on the disaster that you helped
create that is our educational system in
large part it is failing because of the
Unholy political Alliance that you have
with the teachers unions and the
Democratic party and meanwhile Joe Biden
he doesn't seem to care about the
shooting at all now watch this should
anger every single American Republican
Democrat conservative liberal doesn't
matter here is he's beginning his speech
Monday he's coming out to talk about the
shooting we have six dead people three
of them are nine years old here's your
president
my name is Joe Biden
I'm Dr Joe Biden's husband
and I eat Chinese ice cream chocolate
chip
I came down because I heard there was
chocolate chip ice cream
by the way I have a whole refrigerator
pool upstairs you think I'm kidding I'm
not
I came down for the ice cream telling
jokes uh now following the remarks Biden
continue to joke and laugh when asked
about the shooting take a look
I believe
[Music]
that I totally believe they would what
do you think of that well I probably
don't know
no I have no idea I'm joking for real
I'm joking come on man anyway six people
innocent people including three
nine-year-old kids murdered at this
Christian School targeted by a
transgender killer and that is what
that's his response joke time ice cream
time seriously look if Democrats can't
use a shooting for political gain they
don't really seem to care about
shootings let me give you an example you
know exhibit a is their deafening
silence on The Daily violence in Chicago
and other big cities uh all across the
country our friend gianno Caldwell my
colleague he lost his little brother in
Chicago that was innocently you know in
the street murdered gunned down that
shouldn't be happening but we don't hear
about the names of people killed in
Chicago or other big cities or other
small towns in large part caused by
let's see defund dismantle no bail laws
and by the way compassion seems to
disappear and their behavior becomes
appalling in fact a so-called trans day
of Vengeance will continue as planned on
Friday in our nation's capital this is
hosted by the trans radical activist
Network whatever that is the
demonstration will continue for three
days now just imagine if this was a Maga
Related Group planning a Maga day of
Vengeance after a hypothetical
maga-related shooting how do you think
Democrats how do you think the media mob
how do you think the FBI politicized
would treat that event and what do you
think of Joe Biden what do you think
he'd have to say then do you think any
of these politicians that are constantly
attacking conservatives Republicans you
think any of them are going to say
anything about this day that's going to
take place what on Friday I doubt it
anyway Kamala Harris may want to tweet
out a link to raise money for the group
and right now by the way amid all the
political posturing Democrats they are
not even able to work on real solutions
to school shootings there are solutions
think about this liberal lawmakers they
just authorize funding what for 87 000
new IRS agents but for just a little bit
more money a little bit Democrats could
have hired enough armed professionals to
guard every single Public School in the
country that amounts to 98 000 schools I
think our kids deserve the same security
as those elected politicians we pay for
those their security and those arrogant
hypocritical Hollywood liberals that are
rich and can hire their own armed guards
now think about that Democrats are no
they're now so deep into their far
left-wing ideology that they're unable
to deliver any real solutions to real
problems and by the way both parties
could get behind that take a look at the
crisis at our border record numbers of
illegal immigrants are now coming across
children's being trafficked and raped in
large numbers our own Sarah Carter's
been down there Time After Time After
Time reporting on this fentanyl heroin
meth cocaine lethal drugs pouring across
that border killing more Americans than
ever before but because because border
security is now what considered racist
in the Democratic party and they ate and
a bet the law breaking well but the
Biden is now doing nothing to stop what
is going on down there it is being run
by cartels they're not stopping the
death the sexual assaults the suffering
the drug trafficking the human
trafficking well yesterday Senator Ted
Cruz he confronted Biden's Homeland
Security secretary mayorkas on this very
issue let's take a look has the crisis
at our Southern border
made Americans less safe yes or no
Senator we are dedicated to the safety
as the crisis made Americans less safe I
don't I don't want a discourse it's a
yes or no question
Senator we have a challenge you refuse
to answer the question how many children
have been sexually assaulted by human
traffickers
under the Biden Administration Senator
this is precisely why we Institute I
don't want a lecture it's a question how
many children have been sexually
assaulted by human traffickers under
your Administration Senator this is this
is exactly why on January 5th again do
you know how many do you know how many
children have been sexually assaulted
this is why we you're going to refuse to
answer that question as well Mr
secretary I want to say to you right now
your behavior is disgraceful and the
deaths the children assaulted the
children raped they are at your feet and
if you had Integrity you would resign
and I will tell you the men and women of
the border patrol they've never had a
political leader undermine them they
despise you Mr secretary because you're
willing to let children be raped
to follow political orders wow powerful
joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else